so just a bit of a recap
I started Aikido
because I wanted somebody's business
moved to Cambridge
got to Orange Belt wanted to do my
Aikido
so I asked the teacher if we could do it
he said yes so I was like he was
concerned he couldn't take another class
on
so twice a week we had Aikido
Thursdays he would teach Tuesdays
ended up I would I seem to be elected to
teach I
I was always trying to put forward my
partner and in the end we we sort of
done the split where he would teach
sometimes not to teach others
it depended when I just got back from a
seminar
between orange belt and first down
I would do twice a week there
once once a week in in London
on a Sunday
and I've done this so non-stop for two
years
after two years I uh I started going I
think I must become first queue
so I don't know how many years it was
since I first started that point I'd
come first here and I thought was then
allowed to go on the Monday night to do
weapons training
in the end a journey becomes very short
it was 56 miles there 56 miles back
the teachers always wanted to go in the
pub being the Hut was in the
Pub grounds and the teachers would
always want to go in the pub afterwards
they were social and that was very nice
because you got a chance to talk to the
senses and they give you pointers and
things you would they thought you could
improve on on the tatami
and I had a very good friend who who
would help me and really give me
pointers he emigrated eventually to New
Zealand
so
some weeks not not all the time because
you know I had got a very busy life as
well at home running a business running
it you know building a family I had my
second child then two girls
so so life had its struggles
the mortgage at that time started off
very low
and recently the mortgage the the
mortgages for people have gone up to I
believe five percent or perhaps even
more
I had to contend for the mortgage
percent raise increase of 16 percent
can you imagine it 16 because in money
terms those days and nowadays are the
same we we aren't in proportion to what
our mortgage was allowed it went up 16
and I just didn't know how
I could keep it working I put my weights
up
that I do remember I'm very worried
about it I took on a lady to answer the
telephone
but from our home not not in the
business
because it was cheaper to do that and
that way the telephone could be answered
while us workers in the main Workshop
could get on with our work and money
so I think I I was a reasonable business
person
so I get to second down and
um not being used much by anybody but
still enjoying my guitar
and I'll just jump in here and say that
even though I was training every week
three times a week
and sometimes four times a week
if I went to London twice
I used to take my Ken or Joe
and I took my kennel Joe from the time I
was
an orange belt I believe it was either
yellow or orange
I'm just going to show you this this
book it's volume one of cytosensis first
volumes
they came out in 1973
and I bought them
uh I think when I had my first ever
credit card I think it was about 1975 I
bought mine
and then I bought I went to London there
was a shop there secure a trading they
were called
they had all five volumes
and they had black and white cine films
cine Super 8
now these films came in a box with uh
cassettes small cassettes with the voice
overs on them
so you'd have to have a cassette player
and a projector
and I bought that as well so I maxed out
on my hundred pound credit card
and I bought the films
and the books and I went home very proud
knowing that I'd got there on the books
and the films
so from then on when I wasn't training
I would and my wife used to go out and I
can't remember what she'd go out for but
anyway but she would go out
or if and that gave me a chance to put
the cine films on
and I had to get the tape just so it
took quite a bit of juggling to get the
voice exactly right with the the actions
on the film of cytosensi so these were
black and white films
I had patio doors in this house so I
could have the projection screen
Shining
so that I could see the projection
screen while I stood outside on my patio
doors
so I would stand there with the Joe and
I what sort of Scentsy I run in stop the
projector go back outside and I would do
the Joe Subarus or whatever
the cards as well on the film
and I used to do this on the nights that
my wife would go out
if I couldn't train in the evenings
each morning
before I went to work I would get up
early and I would go to my garage it was
in a village by the name of grantchester
it's a famous Village
and we had small dogs as well and I
would walk the dogs and take my Ken or
Joe
and down go down by the river where
there was trees and fences and different
things
and I would train every single morning
with Ken or Joe
I done this from when I was uh I believe
a few yeah the whole orange Bell I'd
done what I've been telling you for the
next 23 years
it was not one day I wouldn't train
when I say train
it may have been walking the dogs and I
may have stopped and just trained for 15
minutes
but when I would before I would go to
bed at night at the back door I would
have a can
I've just opened the back door
swing the can perhaps two three times
nothing much but just so that I could
do something before the end of the day
perhaps one there you're thinking that I
was more than a fanatic and yes looking
back on it I totally agree
I would go away on holiday it doesn't
matter what country every country sells
broom handles and you can either use it
as a can or a child
I would be performing on the beach
of course I was a little embarrassed but
the importance of doing it was more
important than worrying about people
watching me
and over the years
many people did
I wasn't satisfied even with all this
progression and all this training
you know you sometimes feel like you're
walking through thick mud
you think you're getting better but
you've got nobody to really answer it
because if the teachers are not using
you for UK anymore all your friends are
finding you really difficult to train
with even though they're happy to it
becomes more like a fight than a then uh
you know done a good workout
I was become more grounded
the things by training daily is you
become more grounded
um your mind expands more you know far
more
I looked around and I found some really
good teachers on on the film
I can use what was run by Stan prannin
who used to at that time do a magazine
in those days
and every month the magazine would come
out
I think it was monthly
maybe quarterly but I I subscribe to it
I thought the only thing I can do is
write to him so I wrote to him and asked
him uh
what he thought of a particular Sensei
who I thought was superb really loved
his beautiful
knee work and smoothness I watched him
do a tennis ten minute demonstration on
his knees then standing and I was in awe
of this master
so I wrote to him and said um about it
he writes back and says thank you for
contacting him but the master who I saw
was quite young he was in his 30s and
even though one day he's sure he would
be a great master
if you want
the one master that he considered the
ultimate best
he said I have to be careful who I say
this to because I interview all of them
and none of them would like it if I tell
you that this is the best and only one
that you should be looking at
and it's very strange because I only
chose cytosancy because he was the only
person at the time who'd done a series
of books and film
now I'm the sort of person who's really
good at copying I'm better at copying
than following books really
and I told you how I copied it with the
film show a bit go and do it look at it
again go and do it again and this is how
I learned
control myself
he suggested cytosency
and I thought well I don't know I've
been watching his films for
such a long time but he looks like a
bull you know he doesn't look smooth and
beautiful and all these flowing things
and yet stand proudly and he's saying
this teacher is the only one that oh
samsi chose to manage his dojo while he
was alive but the dojo senior
and while he could have left the dojo
and all the surroundings to his sons but
he chose
cytosensei and Saito sent his wife
to look after oh Sensei and his wife in
their old age and he also said that he
was his best student
and he was true to his style
and at the time he didn't like what his
son was doing and that's in other films
I now wish to go into that now
so
it my life has been completely
planned out I I wouldn't have believed
in it earlier but but looking back on it
it's been completely planned now
every step I wouldn't change
my friend who I told you about in the
other film had moved and emigrated to
New Zealand
he said oh your teacher I hear is just
retired from the railway it was about 50
I believe such a Cincy
and he's going to come and do a seminar
here
as about 60 people I think it was 62
eventually people and if you can get a
flight out here I'll put you up and pay
for the seminar
so I got the money together went out
there map site I sentency first time I
Abba really drunk alcohol in a big way
I couldn't
I said to him I apologize to a
translator I apologize since he I can't
speak Japanese
this is why I love the man so much he
looked at me and said why would you want
to speak Japanese when you're English
from that day on
he become my master
like a fatherly figure somebody you
could talk to
we talked over the years about how to
design a garden
he asked me how did I prune my roses and
make them better than his roses
we talked about Dojo life
of course a lot of the conversation was
about our sensing
and as I said in my previous uh film
he wasn't the best student no sense he
had
he said
we were driving in this yellow four desk
court and he said I want you with me
where have I got on this trip
so I would sit in the back he would sit
in the front and The Interpreter was an
Andre a Swedish
uchadeshi that he bought with him
doing the translation
and he said you know Thai sensei
was the best student of Sensei ever had
and I said she said he's the only person
who can surpass me
so he said I wasn't the best student
but I stayed with her sansi
I was the one there for 24 unbroken
years
me and my wife looked after a Scentsy
wherever I sense he went I would go when
since he would ring the bell I would run
across from my house to his
as you may know I've since he gave him a
small piece of land told him to build a
bungalow
and to be their beck and call for the
rest of their lives
so he gave his word to our Sensi that
was the partnership made
he carried on until his death
looking after the iwama dojo
trying to
carry on our sets his wishes and his
Aikido form
thank you for listening so far I hope
you're enjoying it
I've now found my master
in New Zealand because he used me he I
grabbed him I attacked him whatever I
done he threw me like a paper airplane
I never knew where I was I never knew
how I got there I didn't know that I
could do High Falls
um but he could might do them on me
completely disorientated me never helped
had that feeling in my life ever before
from any Master not Japanese or English
I then made him my master
for nearly 20 years I believe it was 19
years I
followed him
but previous to that I followed him in
books and film
thank you for listening the story will
continue